la dictée dictée que vous avez faites
vous même il faut le dire alors la
dictée la dictée de la finale est elle
difficile
ah oui bien sûr oui oui oui elle est
très difficile eh bien d'abord parce que
c'est là dit et de la finale et puis
parce qu'il s'agit de départager les
deux cent cinquante deux finalistes qui
sont là devant moi et qui évidemment
puisqu'ils viennent de la province ils
viennent de l'étranger sont tous des
champions ou nationaux régionaux se sont
tous des cracks
alors là je m'adresse aux auditeurs et
aux téléspectateurs n'ayez pas de
complexe fait la dictée très décontracté
si vous faites moins de cinq fautes
vous êtes aussi un ou une craque si vous
faites moins de dix fautes vous est
excellent et si vous faites moins de
quinze fautes c'est pas mal du tout
croyez moi et c'est même très bien alors
j'ai eu le plaisir et l'honneur de
rédiger le texte de la finale texte qui
a été évidemment revu et révisé par le
jury national
je rappelle je rappelle que les juniors
et les seniors des pays non francophones
ne font que la première partie de la
dictée première partie qui est
relativement plus facile si j'ose dire
que la seconde
je rappelle aussi que je dicte la
ponctuation et que d'ailleurs il n'y a
pas de faute de ponctuation comme il n'y
a pas de faute de majuscules ses fautes
là ne sont pas prises en compte
je vais d'abord dé lire le texte en
continu puis ce sera la dictée et enfin
elle sera suivie d'une relecture comme
ça se fait d'ailleurs dans toutes les
écoles du monde les deux cent cinquante
deux finalistes êtes vous prêts oui elle
est tous les téléspectateurs et
auditeurs j'espère vous êtes près aussi
que j'avais un stylo et un papier alors
allons-y en hommage à julien gracq à
emmanuel le roy ladurie administrateurs
dhabi bio tech nationale et à bernard
rapp qui m'a gentiment céder sa tranche
de cake
voici la littérature à l'estomac
c'est le titre entre mon gîte et la
bibliothèque nationale
je suis souvent saisis d'une fringale
irrépressible on a beau dire les
nourritures intellectuelles ne saurait
remplacer le boire et le manger quand le
corps crie famine et que les let motiv
de la fin surgissent continûment ce
n'est la lecture ni de racines ni de la
fontaine ni de chateaubriand qui peut
apaiser une poche stomacale rendu exigu
par le jeune et l'abstinence qu'elle
martyrs que de devoir agen lire des
récits de pique nique extra de l'ip est
sublime et d'agapes excellemment arroser
les festins littéraires font saliver et
en dv les futurs agrégés sans le sou je
me rappelle les goûters de mon enfance
quand mon père me ranger parmi les
fanatiques de la fourchette les ogresses
et les sybarites puis le temps des
vaches maigres est arrivé fin de la
première partie
deuxième partie aujourd'hui je suis
parfois si obsédé par la fin que penché
sur les trésors de la bibliothèque
nationale
je les confonds avec ceux de la
gastronomie manuscrits médiévaux et
fricandeau palimpseste minoens et court
bouillon in folio est seul il s
ainsi que les culs de lampistes aurier
et les cancoillotte très parfumée les
incunables et les pets de nonne les
petits livres et les petits beurre
écrire est un jour l'autobiographie kid
utilement coûté retracera la route qu'on
m'ait qu'on m'avait assuré être la plus
facile racontera ma jeunesse qui s'étend
au chercher tantôt fui qui eût aimé
s'empiffrer qui s'est défendu de
souffrir qui s'est révolté et dont les
privations ont exaucé mon âme
voilà point final
allons-y la littérature à l'estomac
c'est le titre la littérature à
l'estomac entre man gîte et la
bibliothèque nationale virgule entre mon
gîte et la bibliothèque nationale
virgules je suis souvent saisis je suis
souvent saisis
d'une fringale irrépressible d'une
fringale irrépressible points on a beau
dire virgules
on a beau dire virgules
[Musique]
les nourritures intellectuelles les
nourritures intellectuelles ne saurait
remplacer le boire et le manger points
ne saurait remplacer le boire et le
manger points quand le corps crie famine
quand le corps crie famine et que les
let motiv de la fin et que les lettres
motive de la fin surgissent continûment
surgissent continûment virgule ce n'est
la lecture ni de racine
ce n'est la lecture ni de racines ni de
la fontaine
la fontaine ni de châteaubriant ni de
chateaubriand qui peut apaiser une poche
stomacale qui peut apg apaisé par dans
une poche stomacale rendu exigu par le
jeune et l'abstinence point rendue exigu
par le jeune et l'abstinence point à la
ligne
quel martyrs que de devoir virgules quel
martyrs que de devoir virgule agen
virgules
agen virgule lire des récits de pique
nique extra virgule lire des récits de
pique nique extra virgule de l'ip est
sublime de l'ip est sublime et d'agapes
excellemment arrosée et d'agapes
excellemment arrosé point d'exclamation
les festins littéraire les festins
littéraires font saliver et en dv les
festins littéraires font saliver et en
dv les futurs agrégés sans le sou points
les futurs agrégés sans le sou points je
me rappelle les goûters de mon enfance
virgules je me rappelle les goûters de
mon enfance virgules
mon père me ranger quand mon père me
ranger
parmi les fanatiques de la fourchette
virgules parmi les fanatiques de la
fourchette virgule les ogresses et les
sybarites point les ogresses et les
sybarites points puis le temps des
vaches maigres est arrivé point à la
ligne
puis le temps des vaches maigres est
arrivé point à la ligne
c'est fini pour les juniors et c'est
fini pour les seniors b pays non
francophones et je continue pour tous
les autres aujourd'hui virgules
aujourd'hui virgules
je suis parfois si obsédé par la fin je
suis parfois si obsédé par la fin que
virgules
je suis parfois si obsédé par la fin que
virgule pencher sur les trésors de la
bibliothèque nationale virgule pencher
sur les trésors de la bibliothèque
nationale virgules
[Musique]
je les confonds avec ceux de la
gastronomie deux points je les confonds
avec ceux de la gastronomie deux points
manuscrits médiévaux et fricandeau
virgules
palimpseste minoens et court bouillon
virgules infolio et soly laisse virgules
infolio et soly laisse virgule ainsi que
les culs de lampes historiés ainsi que
les culs de lampes historiés
et les cancoillotte très parfumée
virgule et les cancoillotte très
parfumée virgule les incunables et les
pets de nonne virgule les incunables et
les pets de nonne virgules
les petits livres et les petits beurres
points les petits livres et les petits
beurres point à la ligne
écrire est un jour l'autobiographie
écrire elle un jour
l'autobiographie écrire elle un jour
l'autobiographie qui virgule dutil m'en
coûter virgule qui virgules
dutil m'en coûter virgule retracera la
route retracera la route qu'on m'avait
assuré être la plus facile virgule qu'on
m'avait assuré être la plus facile
virgules
racontera ma jeunesse
qui c'est tantôt chercher tantôt fui
virgule racontera ma jeunesse qui s'est
tantôt chercher tantôt fui virgule qui
eût aimé s'empiffrer virgule qui eût
aimé s'empiffrer virgules
qui eût aimé s'empiffrer virgule qui
s'est défendu de souffrir virgule qui
s'est révolté virgule qui s'est révolté
virgule et dont les privations ont
exaucé mon âme point d'interrogation et
dont les privations ont exaucé mon âme
point d'interrogation c'est la fin
je vais procéder à la relecture assez
lentement et en vous donnant la
ponctuation la littérature à l'estomac
en hommage à julien gracq je vous le
rappelle entre mon gîte et la
bibliothèque nationale virgules
je suis souvent saisis d'une fringale
irrépressible points on a beau dire
virgules les nourritures intellectuelles
ne saurait remplacer le boire et le
manger points quand le corps crie famine
et que les leitmotivs de la fin
surgissent continûment virgule ce n'est
la lecture ni de racines ni de la
fontaine ni de chateaubriand qui peut
apaiser une poche stomacale rendu exigu
par le jeune et l'abstinence
point à la ligne
quel martyrs que de devoir virgule agen
virgule lire des récits de pique nique
extra virgule de l'ip est sublime et
d'agapes excellemment arrosé point
d'exclamation les festins littéraires
font saliver et en dv les futurs agrégés
sans le sou points
je me rappelle les goûters de mon
enfance virgules
quand mon père me ranger parmi les
fanatiques de la fourchette les ogresses
et les sybarites points puis le temps
des vaches maigres est arrivé
aujourd'hui virgules je suis parfois si
obsédé par la fin que virgule pencher
sur les trésors de la bibliothèque
nationale virgules je les confonds avec
ceux de la gastronomie deux points
manuscrits médiévaux et fricandeau
virgule palimpseste minoens et court
bouillon virgules infolio est seul il s
virgule ainsi que les culs de lampistes
aurier et les cancoillotte très parfumée
virgule les incunables et les pets de
nonne virgules
les petits livres et les petits beurre
point à la ligne
écrire est un jour l'autobiographie qui
virgules dutil m'en coûter virgule
retracera la route qu'on m'avait assuré
être la plus facile virgule racontera ma
jeunesse qui s'étend au chercher tantôt
fui virgule qui eût aimé s'empiffrer
virgule qui s'est défendu de souffrir
virgule qui s'est révolté virgule et
dont les privations exaucé mon âme point
d'interrogation finale je vous laisse
reprendre vos esprits évidemment alors
c'est vrai pour les téléspectateurs pour
les auditeurs comme pour vous tous
finalistes vous avez plusieurs minutes
pour relire votre copie pour réfléchir
parfois on a tort de réfléchir c'est
souvent la première inspiration est la
bonne enfin chacun a sa méthode bien
entendu je voudrais vous rappeler que le
corrigé de la dictée vous l'aurez
évidemment ce soir dans l'émission de 19
heures et vous l'aurez
au terme de l'émission sur le minitel 36
15 codes apos mais dès cet après midi
vous pouvez
en jouant sur le minitel vous pouvez
faire vos commentaires sur la dictée et
sur ses difficultés
c'est une sorte de sondage dont nous
donnerons le résultat à 19 heures et
puis vous pouvez aussi répondre à des
questions sur l'orthographe et ainsi
gagner des dictionnaires pendant tout
l'après-midi 36 15 codes apos et
puisqu'il nous reste quelques minutes
brigitte je vais en profiter pour
remercier bien tous ceux sans qui il n'y
aurait pas de championnat d'orthographe
sans qui il n'y aurait pas cette
fantastique que ferveur de la
francophonie au tour d'une autre langue
j'aurais remercier d'abord monsieur
philippe jaffré qui est le directeur
général du crédit agricole
alors vous savez que le rôle d'une
banque c'est de compter et bien le seul
moment le crédit agricole ne compte pas
c'est pendant les championnats
d'orthographe
alors monsieur jaffré remercier tous vos
collaborateurs des caisses régionales
pour leur efficacité dans l'organisation
des demi finales et puis aussi pour
l'organisation de la filiale scolaires
devraient remercier aussi madame eux
dominique alduy qui est directeur
général de fr3 les faire 3 qui a
superbement organisé les demi finales
avec le concours agricole remercier
monsieur roger gousse
qui est délégué général de l'alliance
française et c'est l'alliance française
qui a sélectionné dans le monde dans
tous les pays non francophones les
candidats dont les finalistes sont
l'assaut
cet après midi remercier aussi monsieur
rené la pohdh qui est un partenaire
enthousiaste il est le pdg du téat etc
il a offert plusieurs dizaines de
billets aux candidats venus du monde
entier et remercier aussi monsieur
gérard orizet quel directeur général
adjoint de france célèbre compagnie a
offert également plusieurs dizaines de
billets d'avion
pour tous ces gens qui viennent je vous
rappelle de corée du japon de du
moyen-orient d'amérique etc
et puis remercié aussi spécialement
monsieur jean claude noël qui est le
président de hilton international qui a
offert tout est bien 700 nuitées 700
nuitées au hilton de paris pour les
concurrents de la finale romandie tous
ses clients habituels ont été virés et
ce entre les candidats qui ont pris les
chambres merci merci on a un peu exagéré
la mieux merci beaucoup
voilà brigitte oui je suis là entre nous
je pense que votre parallèle entre les
trésors la biotech nationale et les
trésors la gastronomie vont laisser
quelques mauvais souvenirs
c'était vraiment particulier en dire
alors donc bernard c'est vrai on aura le
corriger ce soir à partir de 19h
rajoutons que poux sur le minitel on
peut aussi faire des commentaires c'est
à dire dire aussi les dict était
difficile aux papillons donnera les
résultats ce soir on peut même âge
huriez insoumis en pivot ce [ __ ] c'est
un sadique on peut tout à fait se
défouler après avoir bien tenais donc on
se retrouvera ce soir 19 il y aura des
questions subsistent et apostrophe qui
se règle est claire oui ça c'est pas
pour les téléspectateurs c'est pour les
250 deux finalistes vont rester parce
que évidemment s'il ya des candidats par
exemple ait plusieurs candidats 0 photo
il me faut tout une faute il faut bien
les départager donc nous allons les
départager dans quelques minutes mais
hors antenne et aussi les auditeurs de
france inter n'auront pas droit parce
qu'il ya d'autres émissions qui vont
venir ok c'est pas monopoliser l'antenne
quand même alors le jre maintenant on va
commencer à travailler tout l'après midi
donc rendez-vous pour tout le monde
à 19 heures ce soir le corriger la
dictée corrigé de la dictée nous aurons
donc les commentaires indiquent t puis
la remise des prix bien entendu ici
les seniors amateurs les seniors
professionnels les juniors et tout cela
pour les français les francophones et
les pays étrangers non francophones
c'est ça donc il y aura neuf récompenses
plus quelques récompenses subsidiaire
spéciale au fait maintenant on joue un
peu notre festival de cannes nous avions
des prix tout études sont tellement
nombreux et tellement sympathique il est
bien normal que ils repartent avec des
récompenses dans leur pays
et puis évidemment il y aura les quel
sera le champion français ce sera
évidemment le grand suspense de la
soirée alors découverte tout à l'heure
retrouvez-nous à partir de 19h sur
antenne 2
d'ici là bonne après-midi et puis bon
courage pour le jury qui va plancher au
revoir à tout à l'heure
[Musique]